[Aplausos]
hola buenas tardes como estamos
bueno como decía rodrigo yo soy marisol
suárez
luego de la upc
la verdad que me siento muy entusiasmada
y muy contenta de estar aquí con ustedes
desde que me dijeron que iba a poder
tener la experiencia de estar acá en el
télex y la verdad que para mí fue muy
lindo no y me comencé a preguntar de qué
les hablo
educación qué es lo que normalmente me
piden hablar de innovación y luego me
dijeron marisol el tema es abierto y
dije qué linda oportunidad para poder
hablarles de marisol suárez
marisol suárez la persona la madre la
amiga la profesional
yo
vengo a compartir hoy día con ustedes
luego a compartir con ustedes mi
experiencia y poder reflexionar con
ustedes todo lo que iba aprendiendo en
el camino de lo que me ha llevado a
donde estoy yo hoy
entonces el día de hoy quiero poder
compartir con ustedes un poco y
conversar con qué es el éxito es la
primera reflexión
el éxito para mí es realmente la
sumatoria de decisiones que tomamos en
la vida las consecuencias de estas
decisiones el éxito no es la suerte por
el contrario por eso es tan importante
tomar buenas decisiones y asegurarnos
que cada decisión que estamos tomando
nos lleva a dónde queremos ir
él
el como nos trazamos el a dónde queremos
ir también es importante
porque todos tenemos que tener una meta
todos tenemos que tener una visión
un sueño
y acá de donde me gustaría conversar con
ustedes no íbamos a hacerlo a manera de
un paralelismo poco por mí de formación
profesional y ahí donde voy a ver el ser
el cio de nuestra propia vida y nos
preguntaremos que hace un siglo
lo que hace es definir la visión a dónde
quieres llevar esta empresa luego el
propósito esta razón que los mueve en el
día a día
luego define el equipo importantísimo
con quienes se va a rodear para lograr
hacer lo que tienen que hacer
se definen las estrategias los planes y
de ahí no hay magia trabajar duro y duro
hasta lograrlo iguales en el caso de
nosotros de nuestras propias vidas
propia vida comienza con definir la
visión
esa visión como la definimos
definimos atreviéndonos a soñar
a dónde queremos llegar que queremos
lograr de nuestras vidas
y claro está al lado de esa visión
también cuál es el propósito
el propósito es muy importante el
propósito es aquello que te mueve que te
hace feliz uno se levanta todos los días
diciendo quiero hacer lo que me toca
hacer hoy día
ese propósito y esa visión
es muy importante definirlas
ni con wayne llegamos
y si no sabemos a dónde queremos llegar
acaso por ejemplo cuál es el propósito
el propósito luego descubriendo en el
avanzar de mi caminar
como me llenaba de ilusión y de alegría
el poder contribuir con otras personas
aconsejando los guiándolos ayudándolos a
sacar el máximo potencial de sí mismos
ojo no siempre ha sido así en todos los
trabajos hoy en el trabajo que estoy en
mi rol capaz es más fácil y más directo
porque tengo la capacidad de influenciar
en muchísimos jóvenes lo cual realmente
me hace muy feliz y me siento enamorada
de mi trabajo pero antes he estado
también en otras industrias y en otras
lleva a cabo mi propósito sin capaz de
haberlo pensado tanto de cuál es ese
propósito pero eso que me hacía sentir
en el corazón en el estómago feliz es
cuando podía ayudar a mis a mis reportes
directos a la gente que trabajaba
conmigo a chicos a hijos de amigos que
me decían tomemos un café tía y por
carlos realmente a lograr el buscar cómo
dar más de sí mismos para llegar donde
ellos querían llegar el propósito y me
hace feliz cuando vamos a la visión que
también
cada uno tiene que definir su visión
conociéndose uno tiene que saber muy
bien que le gusta y que le hace feliz ya
la vez tiene que saber también que no te
gusta haber decir señores eso no lo voy
a hacer
por ejemplo cuando era joven había la
famosa fiesta de quinceaños ahora
felizmente lo han cambiado en su mayoría
por viajes
pero en mi época tenía que ir súper
elegante y ya peor todavía tenía que
esperar que te saquen a bailar a mí eso
me parecía de horror
pero como les decía todas mis amigas que
no iba a ir a la fiesta que todas morían
por ir entonces la verdad que me inventé
una excusa que era el deporte yo hacía
mucho deporte lencia no puedo al día
siguiente me tengo que llegar temprano
pero tenía claro que no me gustaba poner
mi visión y porque voy a esto y la
simplicidad de la visión los sueños no
tienen que ser cosas este raras
difíciles para mí mi visión es poder
jubilarme a una edad temprana
s mi sueño poder ya no tener que
trabajar 24/7 y poder disfrutar de mi
familia de mis amigos y de muchos
jóvenes
y poder viajar por ejemplo con mi esposo
y no tener que conocer una ciudad en un
día en el turibús sin bajar a ningún
lado porque tengo que volar y tomar otro
avión porque tenemos que regresar a
trabajar ojalá podamos disfrutarlo y
podernos quedarnos así sin fecha de
regreso
me encantaría no pasear con él tomarnos
un café engreír a los nietos malcriarlos
este y disfrutar de ellos cuando uno
tiene claro su visión su propósito lo
otro que es fundamental es definir el
equipo
si yo tiene que definir quién es su
gerente recursos humanos de finanzas de
marketing en fin y armar un equipo
sólido para trabajar duro y llegar donde
te has planteado cuál es en el caso de
las personas la vida no es fácil el
camino tiene muchas dificultades
entonces qué tenemos que hacer
asegurarnos que estamos con aquellas
personas que no suman que nos empujan
que nos apoyan a llegar a nuestros
sueños ya cumplir nuestro propósito no
estemos al lado gente que nos resta no
estemos al lado de gente negativa
clave valores los valores señores no son
negociables
si la gente con las que ustedes están no
comparte valores
eso te va a pasar la factura no son
amigos de verdad y lo otro júntense con
amigos que les sepan decir con cariño
que cosas no han hecho bien cuáles han
sido sus errores y cómo mejorar como
personas
otros como seres humanos tenemos mucho
para mejorar con un buen amigo te lo va
a decir
la otra parte indispensable
en el equipo es la pareja
la pareja es fundamental tiene que
conocer tus sueños y tú tienes que
conocer los sueños de tu pareja y
asegurarse juntos que están apoyándose
de manera recíproca a llegar a esos
sueños a veces uno dice mira mi pareja
no le encanta mi sueño pero yo sola
puedo no es cierto
la vida el camino para llegar a tu
visión va a ser difícil asegúrate que tu
pareja te apoya te empuja te reta
en mi caso por ejemplo mi esposo ha sido
un gran apoyo desde que éramos jóvenes
en mi vida tan apoyo hemos pasado muchos
momentos difíciles y decisiones que
hemos tenido que tomar para apoyarnos
mutuamente por ejemplo cuando mauricio
tenía un año mi hijo mayor esté los dos
comenzamos recién saliendo
económicamente pues era un momento
difícil para nosotros y me acuerdo
clarito que diego me dice me aceptaron
en la maestría voy a hacer una maestría
full time lo primero que se me vino a la
cabeza es oops un ingreso - y ahora qué
hacemos no pero yo tenía claro cuál era
su sueño yo sabía que dentro de sus
metas estaba hacer su maestría
y lo apoye y lo logró y él fue él estoy
muy feliz con eso luego de muchos años
la vida se la había da vueltas y le tocó
a él apoyarme me ofrecieron a mí la
dirección general de yanbal en méxico él
era gerente general de pasa en el perú y
lo dejo todo y me apoyó
y la verdad que para mí fue sumamente
importante porque fue un gran soporte
con mi familia pero también la verdad
que fue me sorprendió gratamente por el
lado también profesional e
inmediatamente puse una empresa se puso
a cambiar la sacó adelante y siguió
desarrollándose económica y
profesionalmente
y entonces eso te hará
te da paz te da realmente alegría
para la pareja sino las empresas
reclutamos hacemos tres o cuatro
entrevistas de chequeamos
recomendaciones por favor para la pareja
que es para toda la vida
háganlo no están perdiendo tiempo por el
contrario es fundamental
ojo la vida no es fácil
después de que ya tenemos la visión lo
propósito el equipo que nos toca el plan
el plan que nos va a llevar a esa a esas
metas a esa visión no y en ese plan se
van a presentar un montón de cambios uno
va a ser el plan perfecto para llegar y
van a haber muchos cambios en mi vida
por ejemplo yo planifiqué y yo dije
quiero trabajar quiero estudiar en la
mejor universidad y después de estudiar
en la universidad quiero hacer carrera
en una empresa grande importante donde
con mucho esfuerzo mucho trabajo logré
ser la cabeza a esa empresa pensé en un
banco en ese momento y entonces entré a
estudiar a la universidad que yo pensaba
que era la mejor en ese momento y que
paso la vida dos vueltas otra vez
como al año y medio era la época del
terrorismo de la estatización de la
banca y mi padre me dice nos vamos del
país vamos del país y efectivamente nos
fuimos del país
damos una nueva vida y mi padre en menos
de seis meses fracasa económicamente
pero fracasa de verdad fuerte tuvimos
que comenzar de cero
no había opción para estudiar ya
salí de estudiar y me puse a trabajar
mucho dos turnos todos los días porque
yo sabía que las horas del día eran
importantísimas y le tenía que sacar el
jugo para traer más salario a la casa y
poder contribuir con ellos que me habían
apoyado toda la bien siempre en todo lo
que hacía me tocaba a mí
y así lo hice en ese momento e incluso
me acuerdo que yo decía a mí me
encantaba el deporte siempre me gustó el
deporte y yo decía quiero hacer deporte
pero tenía que trabajar y las horas
contaba y el sueldo por hora contaba
entonces que hice me puse a lavar carros
entonces primero trabajaba de cajera en
un supermercado todo el primer turno y
después en la tarde-noche lavacarros y
la verdad que si se sudado
era un buen deporte sí y así también han
habido cambios en mi camino cambiado de
empresa he cambiado países a cambio y
volver a reinventarse
ante sales de tu zona de confort o
vuelves a sentir un poquito de susto no
hubo de bueno esa te vuelves a levantar
y vas aprendiendo y aprendiendo mucho de
todos estos cambios
lo otro fundamental errores
los errores son muy buenos les pido que
vayan a hacer errores al propósito no
pero cuando cometan errores aprendan de
ellos y sigan para adelante lo que es
clave es que tengan la visión clara a
donde quieran llegar lo que no se puede
hacer es ir andando un camino sin saber
a dónde quieres llegar eso si no se vale
lo otro
es fundamental en todo esto del éxito
que sigan realmente su corazón
lo que ustedes les hace feliz
a donde quieren llegar pueden cambiar
ojo sus sueños también vale
unos momentos el sueño le va a parecer
lejano le va a parecer que no llegan
tan fe y ciencia los caminos se van a
volver a enderezar y las decisiones van
a fluir
aunque estén sino un sueño nunca estén
sin un donde quieren llegar si eso lo va
a ser sumamente felices
lo otro fundamental ya para acabar
es
felices sean felices ustedes ya han
felices a todos los que están alrededor
eso es el propósito que cada uno tenemos
el dar que es algo trascendente
que nos ayuda también nos inspira y la
verdad les digo sean el sello de sus
propias vías y en su vida tengan sueños
no los pierdan y luchen fuerte por ellos
ustedes se los merecen más que nadie esa
fuerza para ustedes también para la
empresa en la que están pero para
ustedes con mayor razón ustedes se lo
merecen
gracias
[Música]